So ribosomes are the molecular machinery that carry
up the process of translation. Then that means
they are going to the mRNA sequence, read it codon by codon and spit out an
amino acid for each codon. Okay, using only
the one letter abbreviations for the amino acids.
I want you to tell me what would be the sequence for this mRNA. Here it is,
ACAGAUGCC, so forth and so on. And there are
six possible answers. And what I need you to
do, is try to use the genetic code over
here to try to figure out. What would the sequence
of amino acids be, if you were the ribosome
and you had to translate this sequence. I want
you to think about this question. It's not an
easy one. It's not meant to be a trick question,
but you do need to think about it. I want you to try to get
it right the first go round, but it's okay if you don't. You can look
at the genetic code again, try to see what you did wrong. If you get
stuck, go to the forums. See if anyone
else has some helpful advice. And try again.